pas de mystère la taxe soda et bien
répercutée par les fabricants sur le
prix de vente au consommateur
hier c'était une taxe forfaitaire pour
tous ses produits
7 centimes 53 le litre aujourd'hui cet
axe devient proportionnelle au taux de
sucre ajouté plus il y a de sucre puis
la taxe sera élevé jusqu'à 20 centimes
de plus le litre en général on zappe
donc on regarde en gros on a besoin on
vient on prend en général pour jamel et
la teneur en sucre ça c'est vrai il a
fallu que bon qu'on me dise de marteau
marqué en gros comme ça de moins que je
pense que ça va ça ça me désole jean la
taxe elle est passée inaperçue pour vous
aujourd'hui comme nissan a jamais assez
d'argent donc ils vont toujours mettre
des taxes dans ce tous les produits mme
pour moi je continuais à acheter sur
j'ai l'habitude d'acheter si on veut
vraiment être efficace il faut être jeu
des interviews sur yon d'aboutir puisque
au niveau de la sécurité sociale la
sécurité sociale oui je pense qu'il faut
que nous consommateurs on se rebelle
contre l'industrie agroalimentaire
contre les fabricants
il faut qu'on demande plus de
transparence est con con con interdisait
déjà déçu que ce serait bien je vais pas
faire attention du tout certain que ce
n'est pas très efficace alors non c'est
pas dissuasif parce que je vais
continuer à acheter de se faire cesser
ainsi c'est pas quelque chose de ces
pains eurogem pas faire attention
je suis confiant
la taxe baisse à 3 centimes sur les eaux
aromatisées qui contiennent tout de même
40 grammes de sucre par litre et
l'augmentera sur certains sodas ou
nectars de fruits
ils contiennent entre 80 et 200 g de
sucres ajoutés par litre ce qu'ignore
beaucoup de consommateurs sont nos
produits on a tendance à être tellement
habitué donc on se dit en larmes
chut on achète sans savoir qu'il rajoute
d'autres justement le sucre comme vous
dites rhin non c'est très rare si nous
ici on prend le temps de lire les
étiquettes les produits les ingrédients
non ben maintenant je ferai attention
par trente ans avec à peu près 90 g de
sucres ajoutés dans ce produit par litre
non je ne vais pas me regardez pas les
étiquettes sinon j'aurais parce que
j'adore ce produit voilà eu non essai
local tout à l'heure c'est le chanteur
dos à ses locaux la taxe soda veux pas
citer nos industriels à changer leurs
recettes
le débat lui a le mérite d'éclairer le
consommateur sur ses habitudes et les
choix qui s'offre à lui il existe des
boissons sans sucre ajouté ni
édulcorants et du coran eux aussi taxés
par ailleurs